but babe moving out at police this is
the worst possible time please don't do
this
babe garbage huh can I take your garbage
yes sure you know I find the more
garbage in the can the better it feels
to dump it all out I suppose that's why
we let it get so fooled in the first
place so we can start over
here to fix the copier yes sure sure hey
how did she'll talk things a really
broken that's the way we're treat them
it needs to be fist who the hell are you
guys the important question is who are
you Steve well if it isn't mr. Stanley
Carl
[Music]
you need and tube and y'all will trouble
white boy
I was here first
the topic hands sweep this
[Music]
just appeal
there can be only one magical
[Music]
[Applause]
good lord or you alright
well I guess sometimes things have to
come apart before we can put them back
together again
oh you're a magical negro too who you
call a negro bitch
[Music]